the takeaway message of all this quantum
physics stuff is simply this is that we
are energy we're entangled with the
whole field of energy the whole universe
is one interconnected whole and this is
how we are connected to each other
however during our developmental
programming we get beliefs that are
programmed into us by our parents
through our culture and then these
beliefs then become the reality that we
experience historically we Define our
populations based on separateness
separate on Race religion origin of
country it's a separateness that divides
the population an interesting point that
evolution is actually the unification of
everyone come together in harmony then
we have to recognize the programming of
separation is the divisive nature that
is preventing us from evolving into the
future at this time need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today this one from one of
the best Bruce Lipton and my take on his
top 10 rules of success enjoy
I'd like to to show you through an
illustration the simplistic nature of
what's happening to us and I'll say here
are three cells where did these cells
come from they came from the environment
through a process of evolution all
coming from the very same Source well
this is when programming begins and look
what can happen you can program one
child to be a Christian you can program
an identical twin of that child to be a
Muslim or another one of the same
children to be a Jewish child this is
separation is a separation of who they
really are I say no you can't separate
that we all came from the same Source
what we have to recognize is it's the
programming that places the separation
rule number two manifest your life so
many people think when you die you go to
a place called Heaven I go you didn't
understand we were born into heaven this
is where we came to create this is where
we came to experience if you lose the
body and go out there you have
Consciousness that's really great I'm
not saying it's not but here's the
opportunity to what to manifest make
something do something experience
something if you then decide I'm going
to do it metaphor metaverse I go well
then you wasted all these beautiful
receptors that were designed to to have
those wonderful experiences to manifest
them for real more powerful they can do
more at least heaven and yet for most
people to tell I go is it hell because
you can't you know because it's the bad
place I say no it's hell because your
program that you got took away your
creativity
and programmed you to be the victim in a
world that you're actually creating so
as a victim you can create a world of
being a victim
and the idea is yeah but if you're a
master then you can create the world of
being a master you are a great example
of it yeah I I you did driving then you
created uh the wine and then you had the
Cosmetics or the candles and all that
other you know that all that stuff you
you took your mind and took it out and
made creativity what is heaven that's
what it's one what is Heaven is a is a
definition of what you want I said do
you have to die to get what you want to
say no matter of fact it's easier to get
what you want when you're alive because
this is where you can do it so the big
joke is everyone's thinking oh when I
die I'm going to go to heaven and I'm
going Jesus your whole mess The
Experience man it was here is where you
created are you creating Heaven are you
creating hell that was a creation
any ideas if you own it
like you've done like I've done like the
people that you've interviewed on your
program
they have taken over ownership of their
creation
and they're creating the life that they
want and most other people are saying oh
this is against me and my genes aren't
good and this world and that and I'm a
victim and I go
sorry folks you missed the opportunity
to create next time you come back you'll
figure it out maybe rule number three
overcome challenging times it's
interesting because all the people that
are here
are in what is called Evolution yeah
everyone thinks so Evolution takes
millions of years I go no that was the
old version because the new version
shows that Evolution builds up and then
some cataclysmic event drops it and it
builds up again in another cataclysmic
event drops it these are called mass
extinctions five of them have already
occurred the last one when the dinosaurs
were here the planet was lost tropical
forest dinosaurs and everything a comet
a big one hit near Mexico
it caused the Web of Life to Come Undone
all the what happened 75 of all living
things disappeared including the
dinosaurs that was the last mass
extinction today we're in mass
extinction number six and scientist says
well what's causing this one and the
answer is our behavior is destroying
ourselves and the environment the
illness said this the planet is has got
a Health crisis everywhere here in other
words on the jeans and it was like no
it's culture in other words when we are
able to collectively change our Behavior
we can avoid the Mass 66 by 16
Extinction that's the only choice we
have actually and it will work and who
will be left the ones that let go of the
old structure and said I will now put my
life energy into building a new
structure so we have I use the story of
a caterpillar uh that turns into a
butterfly a caterpillar is a voracious
it eats everything it you put a
caterpillar on a plant eat all the
leaves off the plant then I say then
what I say well when the food runs out
it goes into a a chrysalis a pupa a
cocoon a cocoon and then comes out a
butterfly I say the butterfly has the
lightest touch it doesn't even touch the
plant it's flying most of the time the
ver the caterpillar is voracious the
eating of African I say human
civilization is in a caterpillar mode we
are heating up the environment we're
destroying the environment and
everything like this I say but there's a
point where we have to go into the
Cocoon I say why you can't live this way
anymore I say now here's where the issue
that we just talked about
a caterpillar comes in a butterfly comes
out I go but the cells of the
caterpillar which are like miniature
people when the caterpillar was eating
and eating it all up all the cells were
working the muscle cells the digestion
cells everybody's working all the cells
are working no more food
well there's no more digestion so what
about the digestion cells oh they lose
their job there's no more food what
about the muscle cells no we're not
moving anymore there's no place to go
and the muscles I say the community of
cells in the caterpillar break down make
a soup a soup of cells and then what and
here comes the important part
some of the cells are called imaginal
cells
and they have a vision of a different
organization a vision of a butterfly
so what's happening is the caterpillar
cells are breaking down the community
but the imaginal cells are taking those
cells and selling wait we've built
something better we build the butterfly
civilization is is destroying the planet
we can't do it anymore so it says what
you have the transformation you have to
go metamorphosis you have to change from
the voracious human civilization into a
civilization that has a light touch on
the planet and so I say so what it means
I say well in the Cocoon some cells are
breaking down some cells are being built
I say which which one do you want to be
with I say don't hold on to the one
breaking down because it's going to
break down let go of one that's breaking
down put your energy your effort your
action into building the better one that
was coming and so we're in the middle of
this chaos
which is coming down and being built up
and I said your health and your futures
depended on which one of these you want
to hold on to you want to hold on to the
caterpillar you're going to die because
the caterpillar is deaf and the
Butterfly is life and so we're facing at
this moment with the breakdown the jobs
are being lost the economy is crashing
the whole world is in a shaking okay in
this moment of shaking you have a choice
and I say unfortunately too many people
oh I want the old one the old one give
it back to me the old one I said the old
one is the problem
you gotta let go and I say you got to
have Harmony I get worse Harmony I go
vibration what's vibration I go music
you you're creating thoughts or
vibration that's when they put wires on
your head they read it called the
electroencephalogram they're reading
your mind I said what are they reading
vibration
I say so if you change the vibration
change the mind you get another world
and therefore vibration is the key
element of quantum physics
that determines if we're going to build
something or we're going to take
something down depends on the vibration
rule number four eliminate negativity I
mean the first step the first one was so
small and Irrelevant in one sense but so
powerful was I'm working on this going
oh my God I I've been programmed and if
I if I follow the program it's a good
program great but if it's a bad program
I'm going downhill and I remember I was
in my office at the University and one
of my faculty colleagues came in that
day and said okay Bruce what are you
bringing to the faculty party on
Saturday night I want to tell you
faculty party might as well just kill
yourself you go there and everybody's
sitting around with a drink not talking
to each other because they don't really
like it
okay and I thought about that and I
thought I work all damn week
why should I go to a stupid faculty
party and waste the entire time where I
had freedom to create something I would
love to do so on you know just came
right on my mind oh I'm sorry I didn't
realize it was this weekend I have other
plans I can oh I can't I can't go this
weekend I didn't have plans but I just
said that and he looked at me like
you're not going to The Faculty party I
go no and he walked out and the moment
he walked out he went oh crap I just got
Saturday night for me I can do what I
want on Saturday night and I started to
say what's next and it lined up what can
I get rid of that I've been programmed
that this is what we do socially even
though it takes away character quality
joy out of life and I started to
eliminate them and say wait I'm creating
this I don't want to give up my creation
because socially this is what we should
do I said I got my wife man I want to
live it and I have been living a heaven
on Earth life
ever since those days why well with the
help of my partner Margaret who I met at
50 so 40 is a kid's age at 50. uh uh and
she she was quite aware of all the stuff
that I talked about we changed we
rewrote our programs beautiful and we
put together what 26 years now oh my God
a honeymoon every day I wake up hey I'm
still alive I've got a great partner we
have a great life I work every day I
wake up it's like wow I'm still here I'm
enjoying every day that I can get it's
called the honeymoon effect
forever wow how'd you do that I say get
rid of the programs that took the joy
away and replace them with programs that
give you Joy also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five be the change you want
to see there's Bruce Lipton has two two
lives Bruce Lipton the guy who lives in
the house and goes to the store and all
that stuff okay and Bruce Lipton the
scientist I go what's the difference
difference I say Bruce Lipton a
scientist knows that from science we are
facing our own extinction because of our
own human behavior Bruce Lipton has a
scientist also knows this if you want to
create a world that we can live in and
sustain ourselves and be healthy we have
to change our Behavior because our
behavior is causing the problem so I
also know what does this mean it says
the structure has to break
to build a better structure a new
civilization because the foundation of
this civilization is creating all the
problems it's the culture and the way we
live with fear and hate and violence and
all that I go a garden which we came
from a garden is the height of
cooperation and we we live in the height
of of war and violence and all this
stuff we live in competition
and the idea is this then the belief
system of this civilization the fear the
competition the war all that stuff
that's part of our creation because
we're creating this physics
let's say you want to change the world
you've got to change the creation and we
have to break this structure because the
structure is perpetuating the problem
yes and this has to go in the chaos
phase let's break down yeah that's right
so science Bruce goes yep it has to
break down because that's how we're
going to build a new one and then Bruce
the guy who lives here goes what a mess
is a crazy mess this is scary
I'm living crazy mess but then Bruce
Lipton science comes in and says you
have to do this because the way you have
been living is causing the problem you
have to change
and that's easy to say but if you're out
there in the world as a working person
and everything and you have to
experience it's like it's falling apart
I go that scares people scares people
stress hormones stress hormones stop
thinking and listen to whatever they
said on a TV or the web don't think shut
down your your health why because I'm
running from that tiger because I am
scared and the point is then the health
issues got worse just watching the news
you walk away with the stress hormones
coming in they're like oh you just all
of a sudden made your system worse
because the stress hormones are going to
compromise you rule number six rewrite
your life the things that you wish for
desire want in your life and you have to
work hard sweat over it I'm putting a
lot of effort in I'm gonna make I'm
working I'm working on it I go why are
you working so hard the answer is
beautiful because whatever that
destination is you don't have a program
to support it and you're trying to
override a habit that doesn't give you
what you want by putting more effort
into it and I go good idea not good
process why 95 of your life is coming
from a program uh and five percent from
this little conscious mind up here
cannot mathematically if you think about
the subconscious a million times more
powerful programmer than the conscious
mind I say and you want to write
override the subconscious I go boy
that's a [ __ ] that's not gonna work
very well uh and yet there are ways to
do it because if it didn't this is going
to be a lousy interview but there are
ways to rewrite it and the idea about it
is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life and change the
outcome you can change these programs
sometimes in 15 minutes or less okay but
you need to know how to do it okay uh
the relevance about all this is um uh uh
the movie The Matrix uh it's all science
fiction I go no no no movie The Matrix
is a documentary what do you mean I go
premise everybody's been programming go
oh that's a given we are all programmed
from last trimester to age seven
everyone is but in the movie they say
well you can take a red pill and get out
of the program
and I want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed okay when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love I go what do you mean I go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later oh life is so
beautiful I'm so in love I'm so happy
look I'm glowing look I got growth
hormone in my system I go 24 hours later
after blah blah blah all those years and
24 hours later you manifest heaven on
Earth I go how'd that happen and the
answer is beautiful because the answer
is when you fall in love you stop
thinking you stay present it's called
staying mindful like what does that mean
I say when you're thinking is when the
subconscious autopilot kicks in if
you're not thinking then the conscious
creative mind is the one that's
manifesting your life so I go the moment
you fell in love why would you think and
the reason this is you've been waiting
for this person your whole life they
showed up you want to think and
disconnect from this I go no you want to
stay present you want to be mindful you
want to be there like oh you stop
thinking I said what's the result
it's the red pill the moment you stop
thinking is you're not diverting to the
subconscious anymore you are operating
from conscious wishes and desires and so
the honeymoon is not an accident it's a
manifestation that says I'm not playing
the program rule number seven don't be
stressed out you're being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger I say you you need
energy to to survive you have to run I
said where's the energy going to go I
said well energy is in the blood that's
what carries the energy I say when the
stress hormones come in because the
tiger is chasing you
it does several things it shuts off the
blood flow to the the gut the viscera
all the organs pancreas stomach
intestines I go it shuts off the blood
supply I say why I don't need to fix and
maintain the body if the tiger is going
to catch me and then I don't that's a
waste of my energy I want all the energy
go to my arms and legs Escape so I say
stress hormones shut off the the
mechanism of the viscera the growth and
maintenance of the body while you're
being chased I said what else and here
comes the one that you were bringing up
when when we're really sick
you don't have a lot of energy to even
get out of bed because the immune system
uses a lot of energy to keep you healthy
I go so I'm being chased by a tiger
and I have a bacterial infection so I'm
putting energy in to run away and
putting energy into the infection I go
why do you worry about the infection
because if the tiger catches you the
infection is not a problem anymore
you're done okay so the this is the
point you brought up and this is the
most important point for the audience to
understand
stress hormone shut off the immune
system so that the energy can be used to
run away from the tiger before being
used to fight the bacteria
and this is the most important
understanding because stress is the
cause of over 90 percent of illness on
this planet everyone thinks genes are
causing the illness I go less than one
percent of illnesses connected to genes
ninety percent of illness is stress
because when you put the stress hormones
in what do they do they shut off the
maintenance of the body they shut off
the immune system and they even shut off
the intelligence
if the conscious brain the one up in the
front that's connected to you your
person is a slow processor like a slow
computer
the subconscious is like a super fast
computer
if you're being chased by a tiger it's
not the time to think of oh oh
oh I go no no run and so the stress
hormones shut down the blood vessels in
the forebrain where the Consciousness is
pushes the blood with the energy to the
hindbrain where reflexes and reaction no
thinking because thinking is slow so I
say so then stress hormones do three
things number one they shut off the
growth and maintenance of the body
number two they shut down the immune
system which protects you from internal
problem and number three they make you
less intelligent
look at the look at the world today the
stress levels are overriding as I said
90 percent of illness is straight stress
not genetics it's lifestyle it's the
fear it's not living in harmony they
don't have enough good music to bring
Harmony into their world they're they're
on edge
I go well that automatically compromises
your health rule number eight have
morality humans have morality
we're supposed to anyway you know don't
kill things okay uh we're supposed to
have morality
but corporations have no morality they
just have a mission how much money can I
make that is the mission by law of what
a corporation is so I say then that's
why they can do anything let's destroy
the environment if we can make enough
money
and all of a sudden you start to see the
leadership of this world is not really
caring about what the individuals want
they want to appease the money making
part and then the laws come down and and
if it conflicts with a corporate law
then screw the people let's give the
corporation their due and that's once we
gave up and we said humans are like uh
corporations are like humans and have
the power of a human I go no they don't
they have no morality they're nothing
like a human at all uh and uh and we
gave them all the power and this is a
wake-up call for all of us that said
who's caring for you
you know I love it they always talk
about the friendly Banker
when's the banker friendly the banker is
friendly when you have money yeah if you
don't have money Banker's not so
friendly anymore it doesn't care about
you at all you know and I go same thing
pharmaceutical company you got money
we're working with you yeah I don't care
about you if you have no money and we
lost and so the evolution we're facing
right now says we have been driven to
this by a Minds that have no uh care for
an environment take what you want do
what you want throw crap into the water
you know all this kind of stuff dig out
the natural resources every it's like
what's our future if you do this the
answer is it's already happening
Extinction we're not in harmony with
each other obviously and we're not in
harmony with nature
and I say well that you got two choices
here
follow the money
or follow the Harmony
and right now unfortunately this is a
tug of war and corporates are winning
because fear because once you're afraid
you give up power fear is a definition
I'm not I'm afraid like well then who's
going to help you who's got the biggest
stick yeah who's the one with the
biggest clown let's give them the power
and I'll wait here for them to fix it
and I go
they're clubbing you over that at this
point uh and we have to wake up I'm
sorry I went on a tirade rule number
nine learn how the brain works an adult
has all different ranges of vibrations
of brain function but when a child is
born for the first two years it has a
very low vibration called Delta and a
child is in Delta well adults when
they're in Delta that's called sleeping
well yeah for the first year and a half
or two of a child's life they spend most
of their time in Delta so that's a
predominant vibration of a child's brain
but around two years of age the
vibration of a child's brain increases
at a higher level of vibration and this
level is called Theta well Theta that's
characterized by imagination and that's
true a child between the ages of two and
seven is mixing the real world and the
imaginary world at the same time so for
example the child is on a broom
pretending it's a horse well to that
child that broom is a horse so if the
mother says give me the Broom the child
looks at her like what are you talking
about because a child really experiences
that as a broom oh on the old famous tea
party where they pour nothing into the
cup and they drink nothing and they go
that was the best tea I ever had well
mixing imagination in the real world is
what happens between ages two and seven
when a child is experiencing Theta but
by time the child reaches seven the
vibration goes a little bit higher and
we call that vibration Alpha and Alpha
is calm Consciousness well that's the
child's life in the beginning of
Consciousness very peaceful and loving
but then around age 12 the vibration
goes up even higher now it's called beta
vibration well beta vibration is the
brain activity when a child is in school
or when an adult is working
and the Beautiful part about this is
every year of the child's life the
vibrations get greater and greater and
then when we're adults we have the whole
range yes at night when we're sleeping
it's Delta and just in the morning
before we wake up call Twilight reverie
the brain kicks into a higher vibration
Theta and then as the alarm clock goes
off and we're ready to wake up the brain
is now an alpha calm Consciousness for
the morning and then on the way to work
the vibration even gets higher now it's
called beta and at work all day long
that's a very high functioning
Consciousness beta you know the
interesting part though is when you come
back home it goes back in Reverse so you
come home from work and you've been
working all day you're in beta and then
when you get home you start to calm down
and relax and the vibration slows down
the alpha calm conscious business and
then guess what the moment you fall
asleep and your eyes close the brain is
now in a lower vibration Theta and then
as you go a little deeper guess what
Delta and you're in sleep and every day
this Cycle Works Delta Theta Alpha Beta
coming home beta Alpha Theta Delta
cycling and cycling well this is really
a very interesting aspect of brain
function for this reason
Theta the brain activity between two and
seven years old for a child is not just
imagination Theta is hypnosis
and this is how a child can download so
much information as a little kid under
seven years of age when we understand
the nature of the progression of our
brain vibration it then becomes
important for parents to know this for a
very important reason when does a child
start to actually downloading Behavior
well very interesting fact even before
the child is born and the last trimester
of pregnancy the brain is already
beginning to hit on Theta and when it's
doing that the child is experiencing
what the mother's experience so a happy
mother is sending happy information to
the baby as programs but a mother who is
afraid frightened not sure of the world
she's living in sounds kind of scary
messages to that feed it says it's
developing and the child is actually
beginning to download these messages the
mother is Head Start program she's the
one that sees the world and her
interpretation of the world is
translated into programs into the baby
even before it's born and why should
they be able to download So Much
Information well think about it this way
how many rules must a child learn to be
a functional member of a family and then
how many more rules must that child
learn to be a functional member of the
community thousands of rules if you
think about it for example how a father
talks to his own child is different than
how the father talks to the neighbor's
child which is different than how the
father talks to the mother which is
different than how the father talks to
the neighbor's wife and that's even
different than how the father talks to
the policeman you got to learn a lot of
rules to grow up and be a functional
member of a family and community and the
idea of can you teach this to a child a
youngster that can't read They're going
to go to school no they're kids so the
most important Insight is that a child
between the age of two and seven is
observing the community so it's
important for us to all recognize that
around children we really must be
behaving at our best and highest level
because we are now programming the
future of that child the problem is this
when we grow up 95 of our life is coming
from the programs that we downloaded
starting even before we were born
through age seven and these kids when
they grow up are going to be the world
that we're moving into these kids are
our future so it really isn't coming
upon us to recognize this we should be
helping them with the best behavior we
must be on our best behavior because
they are copying our Behavior between
ages two and seven especially and
therefore if we want the future to be
better then we have to be better people
as parents as Community as family we
have to be the models that we want these
kids to be because they're watching us
they're recording us and they'll become
us and remember 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is live in
life love it's really interesting to
understand the difference in the
dichotomy between living in love and
living in fear and it's best Illustrated
if I put cells in a Petri dish and I put
nutrients in front of the cells the
cells will move to the nutrients
but if I put toxins in front of the
cells the cells move away from the
toxins the significance is when you're
in a growth situation which is really
what love represents you're open because
growth is open to the world and you
assimilate things and that's where
growth comes from protection is just a
complete opposite protection means
you're threatened your life is
threatened and you wall yourself off in
protection so growth is open and
protection is closed well the relevance
is then you can't be in growth and in
protection at the same time so in our
normal history of biology protection is
a necessary part of our survival you
being chased by a saber-toothed tiger
you seriously have to do something about
this so what Nature has done is created
a protection mechanism
in scientific terms is referred to as
the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
very complicated previous HPA and what
this really represents is the
hypothalamus the part of the brain that
does an interpretation it looks at the
world and says am I in a safe place or
am I in a scary place if the
hypothalamus sees that we're in threat
of any kind it sends a signal to the
pituitary gland the master gland whose
signals coordinate the activity of 50
trillion cells well in the case of a
threat the pituitary gland releases
hormones that activate the adrenal
glands the adrenal system is referred to
as fight or flight
so it's basically a protection mechanism
so I say okay great the HPA axis
hypothalamus sees the threat pituitary
coordinates 50 trillion cells and the
adrenal gland prepares for a protection
response well if you're being chased by
a saber-toothed tiger you're going to
have to use your arms and legs to run
away or fight what you need to do so the
system when under threat releases stress
hormones from the adrenal gland
the adrenal gland allocates all the
energy of the system to run away from
the saber-toothed tiger well that means
the first thing the adrenal gland
activity does is cause the blood vessels
in the gut to constrict this forces the
blood which has the energy to the arms
and legs but then you have to realize
this the moment you shut down the blood
vessels of the gut this is where growth
and maintenance and the necessary
control and stability of the body is
coming from the organs of the viscera so
when you're in a moment of threat you
shut down the energy going to this gut
because you're allocating the energy to
run away
that's one of the first things that
happens as we shut down growth and
maintenance of the body and people say
well growth I'm an adult I don't need to
grow and I go we're made out of 50
trillion cells but every day we lose
billions hundreds of billions of cells
numbers that are just too big to
conceive of actually a normal attrition
aging damage and so basically it says
every day you're losing hundreds of
billions of cells that means by
definition every day you have to replace
hundreds of billions of cells so while
you don't see yourself growing every day
you are growing to match what you're
losing so if you shut down the growth of
the system it won't take very long for
the system to become in a state of
disrepair because if you're not
maintaining the replacement of those
cells this will lead to sickness and
disease and number two remember when the
threat is present the adrenal hormones
are released and stress they shut down
the immune system and this is an effort
to conserve energy to run away from the
tiger what's the result of being in a
state of protection the answer is you
shut down the growth and maintenance of
the body and you shut down the immune
system both of these if sustained for a
period of time will inevitably lead to
disease and death and just to refer back
again to the major why Evolution gave us
this protection response to run away
from the saber-toothed tiger but once
you run away from it once you've made it
away from that tiger
then the system goes back into growth
again so by Nature's understanding
you're only supposed to use the stress
system for very short intervals of time
because it interferes with the normal
functions and then you look at today's
world and we realize 24 7 365 stress
hormones are being released into the
system we read the newspapers we watch
the news we're concerned about the world
and it's unfolding so what was supposed
to be only used for a very short time
has now become chronic and The Chronic
release of stress hormones has resulted
in an elevation of the amount of disease
and sickness that our planet of this
experience experiencing right now so the
significance is we must recover and then
to
where it says we must get out of the
fear that we live in because fear kills
when we're not really feeling well is
that a physical problem or is it
emotional chemical problem well when it
turns out that less than 10 percent of
disease in fact maybe even closer to one
percent of disease is actually connected
to our genetics and our physiology we
have to say then where is our illness
coming from and the answer is not from
the mechanism but from the Consciousness
that is driving that mechanism and this
is the relevance of the new science of
epigenetics versus the old belief called
genetics they both sound the same
genetics epigenetics but there's a
revolution and what's the difference the
belief in genetics is that when I say
this issue this illness or whatever it
is is under genetic control is the
belief that genes are actually
manifesting the problem now there's an
issue about that as far as we know we
didn't pick the genes we came with if we
don't like the characteristics we have
can't change the genes and then we're
also told that genes turn on and off by
themselves elves if you put all that
together you're recognized and you're
not in charge of your life your genes
are controlling your life well that's
the old belief because the new science
is called epigenetics and it sounds the
same but that Epi is a revolution for
this reason Epi means above so for
example what do we call skin
epidermis I said what does it mean the
layer above the dermis Epi Above So I
said then what is epigenetic control
means it simply translates does this
control above the genes
what control is that Consciousness your
perception of your world is what
controls your genes and if you're not
feeling well the issue is you don't have
to change your biology you just have to
change your perception and this will
then give you your power back and this
is why we have to recognize we're not
victims of biology we are masters of our
biology the brain is like a tuning fork
the brain works by electrical vibration
it doesn't see things you know my eyes
are sending in information no it doesn't
see light it sees vibration sound
vibration smell vibration so the brain
is a receiver vibration but now as we
know using what is called
magnetoencephalograph which is like
electroencephalograph EEG yeah EEG I put
my wires on my head and I'm recording
brain activity I'm not recording visual
I'm recording vibrations so we say oh
inside the brain there's a a lot of
electrical activity vibrations which are
turned into meaning okay yeah but the
new device is called
magnetoencephalograph not EEG m-e-g okay
I said what's relevant I say there's a
probe it's reading brain activity you
know what it doesn't touch the head the
probe is out here yeah I've heard you
talk about that well this becomes very
critical because basically if I'm
reading my brain function out here my
brain function is vibration yeah and
what am I reading vibration then it says
not only is my brain taking in vibration
yeah but my brain is sending out
vibration now the immediately we just
talked about construct of and
destructive interference so if a
negative vibration is coming into my
world
my brain using destructive vibrational
frequencies can cancel the negative
around me if something wonderful is
coming into my brain my brain can take
that vibration and and put it in Harmony
and then enhance the power of that
vibration so the the brain has an
opportunity to cancel or enhance any
vibration in the field sorry so that
that
vibration that the brain is putting out
would you translate that to the sound of
your thoughts absolutely vibration is
sound is just a different octave but
it's all sound every but first of all I
mean the hardest part that people you
know it's very difficult for them and it
was even difficult for me even reading
the book on quantum physics is there is
nothing that's physical everything is
energy and vibration and that's very
difficult for the average person like I
was to say I'm looking at you and I said
what a beautiful physical expression and
then to find out there was no physical
expression and I was like what the heck
does that mean and the fact is that we
read vibration yeah and so everything is
vibration in the universe and that's the
bottom line of quantum physics patience
for a simple reason
you have to have patience in
reprogramming because you're dealing
with habits that will automatically
replay themselves every time you're
trying to rewrite a habit so you have to
create a new habit it's not going to
happen the first time or the second time
but as you become aware and conscious of
it every time a negative behavior shows
up and you are becoming more conscious
you are in the power position of
changing that behavior at that moment
and then engaging in behaviors that you
really want
therefore not only does it take patience
but it takes practice so you and your
partner in a relationship have to have
the dialogue with each other when a
behavior shows up that one of the
individuals is is creating and unaware
of then the other person must say look
you perhaps didn't see what you just
said or what you just did automatic
subconscious Behavior Uh it wasn't
really the best thing and through a nice
dialogue and through practice what you
can end up is again leading to an
opportunity to engage with each other
and as a result create new programming
that supports both your wishes and
desires and aspirations and this is the
next and last step of putting that
honeymoon relationship back together
so in conclusion what can we say about
this whole honeymoon effect is this
number one people talk about mind-body
interactions and mind controlling life
and while a lot of people say my mind
wouldn't have created this life
you can go back to a point where you
fell in love and recognize a very simple
truth what you created was not an
accident it was an activation of your
conscious wishes desires and aspirations
you already did create heaven on Earth
the issue is what happened to it and I
said ah the interference from the
subconscious mind if you understand the
programming and how that programming is
the default behavior and you understand
how you can rewrite that programming
then you're given an opportunity to
eliminate the negative programs in your
subconscious that have been sabotaging
you and instead replace them with
behaviors that correspond with your
wishes and desires and when you do that
the so that your conscious mind and your
subconscious mind have the same program
then guess what
at that moment whether you're paying
attention or whether you're not paying
attention you'll be engaged in the
honeymoon experience it never has to go
away The Honeymooners experience that
you could have your whole life this is
why we were here we were here to create
heaven on Earth the one time you did it
is when you fell in love
it could have stayed that way if you
understood the mechanisms we have
described here
but when you do understand the
mechanisms it says you can go back and
recreate that and make it a permanent
way of life you were born into heaven
you've experienced it once or more and
you can do it again and again and again
because that's how powerful you are you
are a Creator and you are in heaven when
you use your creation you will manifest
Heaven every day in your life and enjoy
the beauty of a living experience on
this wonderful planet for me one of the
most personally exciting things that
happened to my life was to recognize
that I was not a victim a victim of my
genes or a victim of my society that I
actually am a creator of my life and
once understanding that nature and
expressing that creativity I profoundly
changed my life from being a victim to
being a master of my creation and today
I have such a wonderful life that it
actually has no comparison to the first
40 years of my life where I lived under
the programming that I received as a
child today I've created such a joyous
wonderful life that I look forward every
day to waking up to have another day on
this beautiful planet All You Need Is
Love and and we really have to recognize
that love is a vibration it's not a
physical thing it's a feeling that
people get and it's it's a Harmony and
this is what love is versus fear love is
Harmony music it all comes together
beautifully fear is noise disharmony and
a Breaking of a vibrational Harmony and
so really it's like bring it back
together again and bring everything back
into harmony the planet the environment
ourselves our community of humanity and
and when it is in harmony it is love
and so that's the message that that was
really brought from this Center uh
through the Beatles
and and given to the world
All You Need Is Love a very important
part of our understanding about life is
that it's our perception of Life which
actually means our beliefs about life so
the significance is if you're going to
plan your life and you're going to make
perceptions the programmer of your life
well then the best thing you can do is
perceive of the life that you would wish
and desire because those thoughts will
be translated by biology into the
expression of your cells and your
genetics and you will manifest your
wishes and your desires and that's what
the new biology is all about the belief
that James turn on and off is taking
power away from the individual because
if the genes were turning on and off and
I did not control them then by
definition I am a victim of which genes
did I get from my family did cancer
genes come in the heart disease genes or
diabetes and now we recognize that in
regard to disease genes are responsible
for less than 10 percent of disease in
fact their indication is that genes are
only responsible for one percent of
disease so all of a sudden it says well
wait we used to think genes cause
disease but if only a small percent of
disease is controlled by genes and where
is the disease coming from that is
affecting the world the answer is now we
know from epigenetics Consciousness
lifestyle belief systems these are the
ultimate controls of the gene we know
that if you've got a cancer Gene and
that's what you believe then you think
I'm going to get the cancer and then you
get a Cancer and you say the genes did
it and now we know no that there is no
cancer Gene there is not one gene that
causes cancer genes are correlated with
cancer meaning if your life is not in
Harmony and you have one of these genes
you can activate a cancer
fifty percent of the women that have the
same brca1 gene never get the cancer the
point is very important having the gene
doesn't mean you've got cancer but
having the Gene and not living in
harmony not living in a healthy
lifestyle that causes the cancer
and so we have to help people take them
from the belief I'm a victim and give
them the science that no your
Consciousness is creating this life
experience in here your Consciousness is
controlling your genes if you change the
picture in your mind you change the
chemistry you change the Fate so I'll
give an example
if I have a picture of Love in My Mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says that
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances Vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture media but now I say but wait
what if I have a picture of fear I go oh
well love chemistry doesn't come out
when fear is in the picture the brain
releases stress hormones and factors
that affect the immune system and growth
of the system and I go oh my goodness I
say why is it relevant changing my
thought changes my chemistry the
chemistry adjusts my biology so if I can
control my thoughts I can control the
chemistry and therefore I control the
biology that takes me to empowerment
Mastery after being programmed by
medicine and biology all these years
that you're just a victim of your genes
that's 100 false genes cannot turn on
and off by themselves they're controlled
by the signals of the environment which
are then controlled by the brain and the
Consciousness and all of a sudden it
says yeah but I control those things I
go yes you do and as a result you have
power
to to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet I asked a question
to the universe which then my cells
answered I asked a question when I just
realized and owned I exist as a
field energy a spirit whatever you want
to call it as information in the field
and it also exists as a body my first
question that came up in my head was
then why have both why have a spirit and
a body why not just be the spirit
and my cells came up with this chorus
that I just blasted my head and it was
kind of funny because I think they have
Jewish Heritage cells because I asked
them a question and they responded in a
question I asked why have both
and all of a sudden welled up and the
answer came and said Bruce if you're
just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden I said oh my God
it's the biology which is all the
receptor devices that translate my
environment into sensation which are
then translated by the nervous system
into fields and and vibrational patterns
which are then sent back to my source
and I realized at that moment I said my
God we're here to experience this place
to touch it and smell it watch sunsets
and feel love and and and and eat
wonderful food and have all this and I
thought wow and then all of a sudden I
said yeah but it's not just receiving
information
when you have a body you can be creative
we can come to this planet and manifest
creativity
and we do this we step into a virtual
reality suit called the body I step into
the suit as a spirit it communicates
with me via just the same way the Mars
rover is communicating with NASA and I
get to experience this planet cells in
your body
outer environment but they have to
adjust themselves to that outer
environment and the relevance about that
well then how they know what to do
because
something has to tell them what the heck
is going on and so it turns out the
nervous system
interfaces the environment and then
sends signals to the cells to tell them
what's going on so the cells are
responding to the perceptions and
actions of the central nervous system I
say why is that relevant because I say
it's an interpretation and so the cells
the simple point you got 50 trillion
citizens and the conscious the mind is a
government yes and the government talks
to these cells now you could have a bad
leader who tells them this is all crap
it's all falling apart things don't work
and it's like they're not going to be
happy cells and it can profoundly
different you talk to yourselves and
tell them okay everything's cool we're
great
when there's a big you know in the U.S
an accident or you know big big problem
in some Community the president goes to
the community yes why does the president
go because it takes the attention of all
the other citizens of the of the states
focuses on the intention where that
president is so if there's an area where
there's a disaster the energy of all the
people are addressed to that area
because the president shows up there and
that's the leader so I'm saying the same
thing for yourselves you're sort of that
president in there and the point is when
you touch some part on your body your
conscious attention focuses on that part
of the body and intention is energy and
it's a healing energy when you're
sending a good message uh to that part
of advice so you touch it talk to it and
it sounds like oh crazy I go no you are
directly sending information to your
Consciousness to all the cells to focus
healing on this part we came here to
create
we came here to experience love we have
a sensory system if it's not love it
takes us away from our creation we came
here to have the joy of what heaven on
Earth and all of a sudden I say Earth is
heaven Earth is where you came to create
and then if you get misdirected in your
creation you can then create the world
that we have a world that doesn't look
that good to me you know uh and I guess
so why is this all relevant is because
we are truly powerful creators and we
have given up the belief that we have
any power at all I'm afraid of this I'm
afraid of that and I'm going well there
you go fear means close down growth is
open they're opposite growth is to be
open and in love fear is to close down
and protection we cannot survive by
closing down anything that closes down
will buy and so we have to it's the fear
and then I say so what about Bruce
because you might ask me that question
What stopped the fear in my life was I
owned my spirituality as a scientific
reality I didn't go through a devotional
phase not spiritual and then I had to
learn a lot of stuff and then I became
spiritual
I was a biologist
and saw I am not in here I am a
broadcast in that moment of I cannot die
you cannot die you're not in there but
you have to not you know like have a
Devotion to spirituality it's either you
believe spirituality you don't believe
it and for me it wasn't a devotion it
was a scientific mechanism
and the relevance was the moment I saw
that my life just like boom
what happened I said I lost fear
and if you're not in fear no one can
control you
because fear is what makes you give up
the power to someone else this is a
truth
but if you really understand this truth
you have to change the way you were
living
because you're living by some
materialistic darwinian Newtonian give
me more matter I'll be happier it's like
there's nothing to do with that at all
because happiness is is not an object
and so what's a revolution well we've
been programmed on materialism
it could be more matter
and it's like no because what do you get
I love it because we did psychic
training session and there was this
professional wrestling
and his
Persona in the ring is like a bad guy
so he has to dress up and you know do
the acting and the wrestling
and everybody would boo-boo him that was
his job to be booed you know and he came
to say okay because he was really
depressed by it why because his job is
to be hated by people it's like well
that's not a great job but uh so we said
well what are you looking for he said
well
if if I could um maybe be an announcer
for this uh you know I could be an
announcer and then they said okay and
you get to be an announcer and what is
that what's that good for well if I get
to be announcer then maybe a network
will pick me up and then I could be a
sportscaster
oh yeah and then what he said well then
I'll have some more money and then what
so then five more things
that was it then I could buy some more
whatever he said and then and finally
you know we kept pushing to the last one
it was like and and what do you get from
getting this and finally after a litany
I'll be happy happiness I'll be happy so
uh remember Rob and I looked at him and
Rob says well you could be happy from
day one you didn't need to do any of
this stuff to be happy because even if
he actually did do all of those yes even
if you simply could say well that was a
circuitous route but at the end it did
bring happiness that would be different
but we know you go through this whole
circuitous route don't pick up at the
end you're still not happy no that's
what the rich people are they got all
this money but they're not happy and
it's like yeah well you could buy
anything you want it's like yeah but at
some point buying is not happy it was I
was happy to have it I said well happy
yeah didn't have to be it happy could be
happy and uh but people have been
programmed
yes to conform to a machine
that requires some a to work and B
consumed work and consume work and
consume and that will make this machine
work like this something you look at in
spontaneous Evolution too is how science
and spirituality are coming together
there used to be very separate usually
absolutely the the scientific World
which is very factual driven and that's
that and you couldn't change it and
spirituality was trying to open up
things but they really are meeting now
aren't they yeah it was interesting
because the spiritual world of religion
was talking about the invisible moving
forces that shape the physical reality
and we call them spirit and then science
only came into existence because it made
a detaunt with the church in the very
early days of science it said look we
won't tread on your invisible spiritual
domain we will just study the physical
world and when Newton was able to
predict the movements of the planet by
just looking at the physical features
then scientists got the ideas well if
you can understand how the universe
operates by just sending in the material
world we don't need that invisible stuff
but in 1925 Newtonian physics was
incorporated subsumed by a bigger
physics called quantum physics and
quantum physics emphasizes the universe
is made out of energy it's not made out
of matter and then I say well what does
the quantum physicists call this energy
that the universe is made of I say well
they call it the field I said what's the
definition of the field I love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world I go my goodness
that's the same definition as spiritual
it's used for spirit and I go yes
quantum physics emphasizing the
invisible uh field as primary to the
physical world is essentially
reiterating the statement of the
spiritual people who talked about the
invisible forces shaping our physical
existence and so by definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality
hopefully the the dogmatic beliefs of
the church which had talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there and science which is still
stuck in its material plane will both
divest themselves of their dogma and
allow us to come together and recognize
that we're all part of that invisible
field that that we don't even live in
our own bodies if you understand the
nature of how the cell works out we are
part of the field being downloaded into
our body that we're all by definition
the field or we're all spiritual same
definition and and if we recognize this
the unity of it and that you cannot be
taken out of the field and you cannot be
in a sense punished by the field you are
the field then maybe the beliefs those
very restrictive beliefs from both
science and from the dogmatic religion
uh will disappear but because the people
owning their own spirituality owning
their own responsibility and not saying
oh which spirits that did this or things
other factors that we are the creators
will generate a new world because what I
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and say if you could create a
world what would you like well I'd like
a world where there's peace and Harmony
and I like some food and a job and I go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief I go then how come
we don't have an answer is because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so I trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together we will create Magic on
this earth like nothing has ever been
seen before so I'm very optimistic about
that how do you rewire your brain well
as we just said the first thing you have
to do is say what the heck are my
programs you don't have to fix a program
if it works the only one you want to fix
is the one that doesn't work so then you
say well what are the programs and I can
already tell you the things that don't
work in your life that you desire to
have in your life and you are creating
an effort and a struggle and a lot of
work to make it happen the reason why
it's not working is because somewhere in
the program it doesn't support that
conclusion so this program does not
allow you to have this so the thing is
well as long as I have this program I'm
never going to get this and even if I
get it it's going to disappear if I you
know as soon as I let go of the control
it's going to disappear because sabotage
away so the first thing is identify well
where are you having trouble
uh and I said whatever that destination
is that the thing you were looking for
whether it was a job Health relationship
whatever if that's where you're having a
trouble recognize this the program is
counter to that it does it's the
opposite the program is the opposite
that's why this can't stay here because
this is gonna 95 of the day create a
different program not the one you wanted
so I say so if I have a troubled
relationship then basically uh my
program for a relationship doesn't work
very well in my case that was true I uh
you know for 50 years I was operating
from the program of relationship that I
downloaded from my parents who had a
really sucky relationship it was so bad
and I was just manifesting it
unconsciously until I started a change
once I changed now I have heaven on
Earth how many people go through the
process find it doesn't work and then
repeat the process and doesn't work
again it's like oh oh yeah I've been
married four times somebody was saying
it's like God they repeated the same
error already three times with the ideas
do you think by the fourth time maybe
you could learn that whatever pattern
you played three times in a row will
probably play itself again until you
change not your partner you keep
bringing in the same partner with
different colored hair and a different
name but you're still you brought that
person in and you play the same game
over again the question is can you learn
the answer is you can but do many people
learn the answer is no because they keep
thinking that it's just my fate you know
that's just the way life is the
subconscious Still Remains unconscious
that's the problem until you change the
subconscious program you it's the
subconscious is a habitual mind it's a
habit until you change the Habit you
will be replay the Habit that's why it's
called a habit so you keep replaying the
same program it's like yeah you keep uh
you know it's like a definition of of
insanity is the idea of keep doing the
same thing and expect something
different to happen the fact is though
that's insane why you keep doing the
same thing you're going to get the same
thing
and if the Habit mind is giving us a
story then the answer says well how do I
change it answers change the
subconscious mind because that's where
the habits are that we got from other
people again this is most important the
fundamental habits in the subconscious
mind came from other people and that's
why they rarely match what you want in
your conscious mind which is you
and you create those programs and yet
the fundamental programs the
subconscious were downloaded during that
first six years of our development
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no